and we are all being cautioned to limit
our interactions for the thanksgiving
holiday to try to really reduce the
spread of covet 19.
of course it is a very different holiday
this year so the experts are
recommending different things one thing
is to keep those interactions
essentially in our bubble our immediate
family if you will
but in some other cultures social
bubbles are encouraged now kirsten joyce
is live in studio
explaining more on how to essentially
kirsten bubble safely
that's right brian but first let's be
clear here when you interact with more
people you do increase your odds of
acquiring and spreading covet 19.
staying home and limiting your
face-to-face contact with people
is still the best way to avoid it but in
new zealand and parts of the uk
social bubbles are encouraged they can
be a very effective way of extending
contact beyond the household if managed
properly
because you commit to only hanging out
with certain individuals all right
this might be what many of you are
already doing you probably already have
your
covet 19 bubble it could be your group
of close friends perhaps
extended family neighbors even your
co-workers but keep in mind
bubbles can also make it a little
difficult to perform contact tracing
so here is how to bubble safely there we
go know about people's health conditions
ask your friends or potential bubble
mates if they have any underlying health
conditions that
could make them more susceptible to
getting covet 19
set some ground rules have a
conversation about what the expectations
are for the group
and know what precautions people have
been taking and one last note feel free
not to bubble even if your best friend
in the world the cdc says
you shouldn't get together with people
who have not been wearing masks or
practicing good hygiene